bonjour c'est latence enfin et pour
beaucoup de personnes les vacances sont
synonymes de convois alors non les
chansons c'est à la fin et c'est moi qui
les chantent en fait dans le port de
masse aléas il ya des marins qui chante
on va parler de la mer quoi al'annonce
de ce sujet peut-être que certains
d'entre vous se disent qu'ils voient pas
vraiment le lien avec l'histoire à moi
qu'on s'embarque dans la géologie ou que
peut-être j'ai basculé du côté géographe
de la force
la réponse est non parce que la mer
n'est pas juste un espace sur lequel des
personnes circulent avec leur petit
bateau mais a au fil des siècles nouer
un lien très fort avec les sociétés
terrestre nous quoi que les géographes
appelle la maritimité la maritimité
c'est donc l'ensemble des liens entre la
mer et les humains et c'est donc à
l'histoire de la maritimité qu'on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui
pendant longtemps les humains et ignore
la nature de la mer c'est pour ça qu'ils
aient imagine tout et son contraire
durant l'antiquité par exemple des
savants tels que platon pense que le
fond des mers est en communication avec
les bouffes terrestre on pense aussi que
l'atlantique et peu profondes ce qui
expliquerait la disparition de
l'atlantide sous l'eau je connais cette
théorie à l'époque on connaît surtout la
méditerranée si on reste centrée sur
l'antiquité bien de chez nous et
l'atlantique comme les profondeurs sont
des espaces probablement infinie
méditerranée signifie d'ailleurs mr du
milieu des terres et elle est
représentée en tant que telle sur les
cartes jusqu'au 15ème siècles au moyen
âge on pense qu'il existe une mère
primordial qui fait le tour de la terre
et alimente toutes les autres mers du
monde
c'est pourquoi des mers fermé comme la
mer caspienne mettre du temps à être
considérés comme des mères elles le sont
à partir du xiiie siècle précisément on
ne sait pas trop non plus d'où vient la
salinité de l'eau de la chaleur ou de
montagne de celles sous marines et
pourquoi la mère ne déborde pas et
pourquoi elle change de couleur parfois
pourquoi les vagues etc
par exemple pour paul diacre qui vit au
viiie siècle il existe un beauf au large
de la norvège qui absorbe les flots deux
fois par jour pour mieux les revenir
ensuite
ce qui explique les marais il existerait
des gouffres semblable entre les deux
bretagne et la gauche
et un autre gouffre au large de
l'adriatique histoire de se répartir le
travail équitablement autour du monde
connu pour d'autres ces marées sont dues
aux astros vent ou à la respiration du
monde et c'est beau pour ce qui est des
limites de la mer ça reste une vaste
question pendant tout le moyen âge la
carte pisane 2290 représente l'ensemble
de la méditerranée
mais on connaît peu le reste de toute
façon nous n'avons pas à franchir les
colonnes d'hercule
des quoi le détroit de gibraltar
effectivement au début du moyen-âge on
pense toujours qu'au delà du détroit se
trouve l'océan ténébreux et mystérieux
et même après son franchissement
jusqu'au 15ème siècle certains
considèrent que l'archipel du cap-vert
marquer la limite à ne pas franchir
une colonne sûr j'ai des flots en aide
une main seraient plantés aux abords des
îles pour faire office de gandalf des
maires ne pas passer tout ça toujours au
moyen-age on pense que la mer est
remplie deal à la fois mystérieuse
éternelle et dangereuse qu'on a tendance
à attribuer à toutes les îles qu'on
découvre les açores les canaris cette
croyance est si forte qu au xvème siècle
une expédition se mettent en place pour
découvrir les mythiques dit brasil en
plus comme on connaît mal et longitude à
cette époque il peut arriver qu'une même
ils sont reportées plusieurs fois sur
une carte sous des noms différents ce
qui rend la mer encore plus bordélique
et mystérieuse ce n'est qu'à partir du
15e siècle on commence à envisager de
parcourir les océans pour rejoindre
l'inde par exemple grâce à ses voyages
les cartes qu'on appelle portulans à
l'époque se multiplient et permettent de
découvrir la géographie du pacifique des
mers australes des côtes américaines
et puis si au passage on peut découvrir
l'atlantide ou la cité engloutie 10
c'est génial oui la logique s'acquiert
pas à tous les niveaux d'un coup ce
n'est qu'au 19e siècle que des
scientifiques etc adopte une approche
vraiment naturaliste pour étudier la mer
avec par exemple d'un jamin franklin
pied le premier a dessiné une carte du
gulf stream
pour ce qui est du fond des mers il
reste longtemps encore plus obscure que
la surface mais en même temps c'est pas
super éclairèrent dans l'antiquité on
s'y intéresse surtout pour éviter que
les bateau s'échoue les seuls jeunes
qu'ils plongent le fond en apnée pour
pêcher des pères ou des éponges et il
leur arrivait aussi d'attaquer leurs
ennemis par en dessous
à partir du xiiie siècle on est capable
de mesurer les fonds à l'aide d'un plomb
placé au bout d'un fil
mais l'impact scientifique reste faible
surtout qu'on va pas se mentir
les hommes de l'époque s'en foutent un
peu ce n'est que 18ème siècle
qu'apparaissent les premières cartes des
fonds des mers
avec marc cilic qui représente la
profondeur du golfe du lion grâce à
différentes courbes qu'on appelle des
courbes iso bat ici on les retrouve pour
la manche par philippe beluche à la même
époque on s'intéresse à la nature des
fonds et à l'impossibilité de trouver
des chaînes de montagne au fond des mers
les seuls à aller vers les profondeurs à
cette époque sont les pêcheurs qui pose
parfois des lignes jusque mille mètres
de profondeur et remonte des poissons
d'espèces inconnues mais encore une fois
les scientifiques s'y intéressent assez
peu le naturaliste edwards ford propose
même la théorie des zones azoïques qui
veut qu'aucune vie marine n'existe au
delà de 3 100 brasse de fond spoiler
c'est faux et il existait déjà des
preuves que non à son époque
en 1841 le galathéa avaient réussi à
poser un filet au fond de la fosse des
mariannes à plus de 9000 mètres de
profondeur et en avait remonté des
espèces d'invertébrés
mais les théories même les plus absurdes
ont parfois la vie dure tout s'accélère
au 19e siècle pour des raisons pratiques
avec le développement des
télécommunications on veut placer les
câbles au fond de l'atlantique
et pour ça il faut bien connaître la
nature des fonds et leur profondeur de
grandes campagnes océaniques ont alors
lieu dans la deuxième moitié du 19e
siècle comme ça du challenger de 1872 à
1876 pour la première fois on traverse
plus l'océan pour aller quelque part où
dans un but économique
mais pour l'océan lui même ses
expéditions permettent de trouver de la
vie jusqu'à plusieurs milliers de mètres
de profondeur ce qui fout en l'air la
théorie de la zone à zurich
toutes ces expéditions permettent un
grand nombre de publications
scientifiques et sont prolongés au 20e
siècle
des artistes comme jules verne s'en
inspire le public adore et ne
terminerons cette première partie sur
les quelques mots de théodore monod pour
définir les abysses il fait noir il fait
froid il fait profond il fait fin c'est
vrai que on a beaucoup parlé de la mer
mais pas encore de ce qui y vit et
pourtant l'imagination humaine la peuple
et de tout un tas de créatures au fil
des siècles
dès l'antiquité on pense que la mer est
le royaume de poséidon que les courants
sont provoqués par charité sylla et que
croiser des sirènes s'avère plutôt
dangereux j'ai lu dans un vieux livre
une histoire sur un certain unis où on
connaît les sirènes sont des femmes qui
ont tendance à attirer les hommes vers
les profondeurs par leurs chants mais il
leur arrive aussi parfois de les avertir
de l'imminence d'une tempête
christophe colomb déclarant n'avoir
aperçu en 1493 lors de son voyage en
amérique tu veux dire l'asie
elle a pas encore compris mais il se dit
aussi déçu par leur beauté ce qui fait
qu'il est plus probable qu'il ait croisé
des lamantins est en effet un matin
c'est pas très sexy parmi les autres
créatures imaginées on trouve des
baleines dans tu dévorant les hommes des
rhinocéros marins les chevaux marins des
écrevisses géante serpent de mer des
poissons en habit de moine
on retrouve ces créatures dans les atlas
et les livres de cosmographie à partir
du 11e siècle et jusqu'au xviie siècle
où ils sont classifiés comme n'importe
quel autre animal par exemple le kraken
est considéré comme faisant partie de la
faune de suède dans les magouilles mundi
de pierre d'ailly début du xvème siècle
on trouve des serpents merci long qui
peuvent traverser les océans et des
écrevisses qui font la taille d'éléphant
l'une des caractéristiques des monstres
marins
ils sont énormes on croit aussi en
l'existence du poisson licorne
ce qui au final n'est pas illogique du
tout parmi les créatures qui reviennent
souvent on trouve le poulpe géant soient
croisés en mer soit échoué et parfois
même la scène géante ses poules sont
souvent présentés comme les créatures
les plus meurtrières du monde marin ils
sont décrits par jules michelet en des
termes qui ferait pâlir lovecraft il
offre l'aspect étrange ridicule
caricaturale d'un foetus cruel furieux
moore transparent mais tendu soufflant
d'un souffle meurtrier de nombreux
témoignages parlent de poulpe ayant
saisi des matelots par ses bras ou fait
couler un bateau pour renforcer l'effet
il aime surtout attaqué pendant les
tempêtes
parmi les autres créatures bien
meurtrière se trouve la baleine elle
attaque les navires parce qu'elle aime
tuer parce que c'est son territoire non
mais une autre croyance plutôt répandu
du 12e au xviiie siècle celle des hommes
mara il apparaît surtout sur les côtes
bretonnes et ce sont des sortes d'un
poisson qui viennent avertir les hommes
de tempête
de manière générale les créatures des
mères sont souvent des hybrides comme
les sirènes et sangliers de mer même les
serpents de mer qui d'après de nombreux
témoignages très fiable aurait aussi une
tête de cheval
un autre mythe très connues même s'il
n'est pas vraiment lié à une créature et
celui du hollandais volant
de manière générale celui des bateaux
fantômes depuis le 6e siècle
on pensait que les morts étaient
emportées par barque vers l'ouest c'est
qu'on pouvait parfois les croisés sur
l'océan cette croyance est reprise dans
les années 1840 à dieppe où les
habitants disent voir le jour des morts
l'un des navires disparus pendant
l'année apparaître au bout de la jetée
si ce n'est pas un plagiat du styx je ne
sais pas ce que c'est mais c'est pas
romaine toi enfin d'après la légende
le landais volant serait un bateau du
xviie siècle dont le capitaine aurait
mis 90 jours seulement pour rejoindre
amsterdam au lieu de huit mois
d'habitude parce qu'il aurait passé un
pacte avec le diable serait depuis
condamnés à errer sur les mers il existe
plusieurs versions comme pour toutes les
légendes mais méfiez vous si vous
croisez un navire avec un pavillon noir
même si vous entendez décrit l'équipage
surgir de nulle part aux landais volant
approche les raisons pour lesquelles des
marins racontait ce genre d'histoire
peuvent être multiples déjà ils ont pu
confondre ces créatures avec des phoques
des lamantins des baleines ou dans le
cadre de flamme qui surgirait des maires
ça pourrait être des éruptions
volcaniques
au niveau des rifts ensuite il est très
probable que les marins aimé inventer ce
genre d'histoire parce que ça faisait
toujours plus casque dire j'ai tout
bartier pêcher à moi où je me suis bien
fait chier 1
il est aussi possible que des créatures
mythiques et parfois été inventé pour
dissuader un peuple d'aller se promener
dans telle ou telle mère très
géopolitique tout ça et pour ce qui est
des récits qui reprenait ses mythes se
vendait super bien dans la presse à
partir du xviiie siècle puis dans les
romans au 19e siècle avec jules verne
victor hugo dans les opéras de wagner et
même en objets de décoration ils ont un
succès monstre depuis le 20e siècle les
scientifiques essayent de trouver des
explications logiques à toutes ses
apparitions monstres les poissons des
abysses sont beaucoup mieux connu on a
prouvé l'existence des vagues scélérates
qui revenait souvent dans les lacie pour
ce qui est des bateaux fantômes ils
pourraient être des mirage ou des épaves
à la dérive bien réel
il peut être que j'aborderai ce sujet un
jour boutefeu hardy mode fut courtois
le premier qui fait une f et se mit en
mer sous le vent cherchant terre qui ne
voyaient
et rivages qui l'ignoré entre les
rivages inconnus
les créatures marines la mère fait peur
pendant très longtemps on prend la mer
par nécessité pour atteindre le rivage
de l'autre côté ou pour des intérêts
économiques mais pas par amour de la mer
si c'est le cas le rarement longtemps
dès l'antiquité avec l'odyssée la mer
est hostile les meurtrières et dressent
des obstacles face aux marins qui n'ont
pas choisi de faire ce long voyage
du coup au moyen âge on m'associe la mer
allant faire carrément les froides
humide
chaque fois qu'elle apparaît dans la
bible c'est pour montrer que du est en
colère le pire c'est l'atlantique le
soleil s'y couche dirait la mort elle
est aussi imprévisible même si au moyen
âge des tempêtes sont plutôt bien
acceptée parce qu'on considère que c'est
une punition divine si on la méritait ça
va néanmoins d'après le journal de
christophe colomb les marins ne la
ramène pas trop s'il s'agit de perdre la
terre de vue on pense que franchir
l'atlantique pourrait amener les marins
vers un chaudron bouillant située à
l'équateur ou rendre la peau des marins
noir une autre citation du xviie siècle
dit être sur un bateau c'est être en
prison avec le risque d'être coulé une
autre raison pour laquelle la mère fait
peur et qu'on ne peut pas y respirer
quiconque se noie en mer devient perdu
anonyme et sans sépulture toujours dans
l'odyssée d'ulysse aurait préféré mourir
à trois que finir noyé dans les récits
de croisade la tempête est presque plus
redoutés que la guerre parce que mourir
en mer est vu comme un digne d'un
chevalier on se demande si les noyers
meurt vraiment si ce sont les proies des
monstres marins
si le ram est condamné à errer en mer et
puis parfois le danger en mer vient des
hommes
et pour ça je vous renvoie à mon double
épisode sur la piraterie l'autopromo ici
où on ça va et puis il faut pas oublier
le mal de mer qu'on retrouve aussi dans
beaucoup des témoignages des marins et
qui le rendent vraiment mal genre
incapable de bouger et je parle
d'expérience
et puis il ya le climat les conditions
de vie à bord les maladies toutes ces
joyeusetés dont on parlera plus tard et
qu'ils ne rendent pas vraiment le voyage
agréable pour toutes ces raisons les
récits qui comporte en voyage en mer le
décrit souvent comme une punition
par exemple le dit du vieux marin est
une ballade de samuel coleridge écrite
en 1798 dans laquelle un vieux marin est
condamné à errer de par le monde parce
qu'il a tué un albatros on retrouve
cette idée chez allan poe ou herrmann
ville qui était lui-même marin avant
d'écrire moby dick ce n'est qu'à la fin
du xviiie siècle qu'on commence à se
dire que la mer dangereuse calais et
quand même pas si moche surtout les
tempêtes c'est dangereux mais c'est beau
une tempête parle alors d'horreur
exquise et les peintures de tempête
comme celle de turner deviennent très
répandue et les romands aussi d'ailleurs
la scène de tempête c'est le
rebondissement incontournable des récits
de voyage c'est soit une tempête soit un
vieux et malgré toutes ces peurs tous
ces dangers qui sont autant de chance la
mer attire à tout le monde mais elle
attire alors comment l'expliquer on peut
penser à une nécessité déjà qui surpasse
la peur histoire de plomber l'ambiance
dès le départ on a vu que le risque de
noyade était l'une des raisons pour
laquelle la mère fait peur et pourtant
des centaines de réfugiés traversent la
méditerranée de nos jours il existe des
marins qui disent avoir une vocation
entendre l'appel de la mère ou la sentir
le vent et le danger même si certains
regrettent ensuite on a l'exemple d'une
jeune fille de 15 ans anne pommeraie
s'embarque en 1780 parce qu'elle voulait
voir la mer et elle prend le nom de
louis renault renault en plus c'est pas
un don qui prend la mer
je ne comprends pas vos références est
exaspérant certains se trouvent aussi
plus curieux non pas de la mer en
elle-même mais des rivages qui se trouve
derrière suffisamment pour vouloir
marquer c'est le cas des grands
navigateurs du 16e siècle comme magellan
et plus tard de lapérouse bougainville
kerguelen cook et c'est leur équipage a
probablement peur de partir vers
l'inconnu et d'affronter du pont de
glace pour certaines expéditions
australe mais au moins le chef de
l'expédition est motivé et ça peut
suffire à motiver les autres là des
terres pour d'autres les raisons sont
plutôt économique être marin aux
pêcheurs ça paye la famille restés
derrière tout simplement
et même si les marins sont parmi les
catégories les plus pauvres de la
population
la troisième raison est qu'on veut faire
comme faisait les parents en bretagne au
xviiie siècle
45% des marins sont eux-mêmes fils de
marc et puis certains ne veulent pas
embarquer en fait les embarquements
forcées sont employés en angleterre à
partir de la guerre de cent ans
on appelle ça le système de la presse
nous vous pressons d'embarquer à coups
de gourdin dans le nez effectivement de
presse dieng était lâché dans les
quartiers maritimes armées de gourdins
et enrôlée de force les passants les
déserteurs légende rivières etc
au xviie siècle ce système assure près
de 40% des enrôlements mais les gens
commencent à râler
se rebeller contre des places gagne le
système va ce que quand même en place
jusque 1869
la france n'est pas plus glorieuse
puisqu'elle met en place pour les
communautés littoral à partir de 1670
une conscription obligatoire qui visent
des marins âgés de 18 à 55 ans pour
qu'ils servent dans les vaisseaux royaux
elle élargit même cette conscription aux
pêcheurs à pied et aux gens de rivière
ce qui fait que tu peux tranquillement
péché l'as moulins jour est retrouvée
matelot de guerre le lendemain ce
système est remaniée à la révolution
mais il persiste ensuite jusqu'en 1965
où il est fusionné avec le service
militaire classique pour faire face à la
pénurie marin on engage aussi des
mousses très jeune
l'âge légal et 12 ans mais ça peut
descendre jusqu'à 8 ou à des étrangers
aussi européens parfois même indien mal
et africains chinois
tout ça grâce au développement du
commerce international par contre pour
s'entendre à bord je vous raconte pas là
des lettres qui es-tu allé faire dans
cette galère
puisque cet épisode est déjà très long
j'ai décidé de le couper en deux parties
le sujet de la mer et de très vastes
comme la mer et je m'en suis rendu
compte en faisant mes recherches ce qui
explique pourquoi j'ai mis autant de
temps à sortir pour vous teese est un
peu la prochaine fois on parlera de la
vie des marins mais aussi des relations
entre les gens qui vivent au bord de la
mer et la mer et enfin des moyens par
lesquels les marins se protéger contre
tous les dangers qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
une partie de palpitant donc je ne
voulais pas manquer et pour rester dans
le domaine de la mer j'annonce que le
prochain jean todt i'm bad ass qui sera
probablement la prochaine vidéo de la
chaîne parlera d'une femme sur un bateau
mystère à bientôt donc
et les grandes vacances et le tournage
du time warp aidant je peux pas vraiment
dire quand le prochain épisode sortira
mais j'ai déjà hâte de le faire en
attendant vous pouvez vous retrouver mes
folles aventures de vidéastes sur
facebook twitter me soutenir sur tipi
le ski est gratuit partager les vidéos
et puis aller à la mer ou pas d'ailleurs
vous faites ce que vous voulez moi
j'aime pas trop la mer ça gratte et puis
le salon suite à col non c'est vraiment
dégueulasse la mer plus de la montagne
[Musique]
force et sa puissance
c'est
moi le cas j'aurais passé
le gouverneur
voilà sans doute
[Musique]
il
c'est
avant notre ère et par email